und in brüssel bin ich jetzt zum phönix
tagesgespräch verbunden digital mit
katharina wagner spd sie ist
vizepräsidentin des europaparlaments
cavalli die sonne aus konflikt bewegt
natürlich auch die europäer
die vereinten nationen haben bisher
keine gemeinsame position finden können
nun ist europa am zug wie einig dass
europa in dieser frage nun die
europäische union hat immer in einer
gemeinsamen stellungnahme abgegeben im
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
hat ein sofortiges ende der angriffe der
hamas gefordert das
selbstverteidigungsrecht israels betont
auch nochmal auf die zwei-staaten-lösung
hingewiesen hingewirkt aber natürlich
gehört auch dazu wir sind 27
mitgliedsstaaten und da gehen die
meinungen auch durchaus auseinander
also es ist schon ein kraftakt dieser 27
staaten dort auch wirklich zusammen zu
binden
quasi zwei ereignisse dazu heute in
brüssel wir haben ab 14 uhr eine
dringlichkeitssitzung der
eu-außenminister aber wir haben auch das
europäische parlament was ich später am
nachmittag mit dieser frage befassen
wird
im grunde genommen geht es ja um die
frage was kann die europäische union zur
deeskalation ganz praktisch beitragen
ja die europäische nun kann natürlich
diplomatisch tätig werden wobei sich
bisher in diesem konflikt ja eher
bewährt hat in kleineren formaten zu
agieren also beispielsweise platform a
tvo hecken maß sehr aktiv ist unser
außenminister gemeinsam mit jordanien
und frankreich bislang sind es eher
diese kleineren runden die fortschritte
erzielen können aber natürlich muss auch
die europäische union als ganzes
diplomatisch tätig vor allem die
klaviatur der diplomatie bietet hier
einige möglichkeiten um sozusagen aus so
einem konflikt herauszukommen da geht es
erst mal um eine feuerpause dann
vielleicht doch eine waffenruhe und
später vielleicht um einen vertraglich
fixierten waffenstillstand worum geht es
aus ihrer sicht jetzt zuerst
in erster linie geht es jetzt darum dass
die gewalt endet die insbesondere
natürlich die attacken der hamas auf
israelisches gebiet aber auch die
unruhen die in dem ganzen gebiet
herrschen die sind ja verschiedenen spur
also das ist erstmal das wichtigste dass
die opfer unter der zivilbevölkerung
vermieden werden dass die die gewalt
aufhört das muss das allererste ziel
sein es ist ja wir wissen es alle nicht
so als wäre das ein konflikt der gestern
entstanden ist das hat eine lange lange
geschichte also die route die sie auf
gezeigt haben ist natürlich das ziel
aber das ist ein langer weg vorbei denn
und gibt die europäische union seit
jahren relativ viel geld in die
palästinensischen autonomiegebiete
dennoch muss man eigentlich fragen wer
ist eigentlich der ansprechpartner der
eu der gesprächspartner auf seiten der
palästinenser insbesondere sozusagen
dann der radikalen palästinenser das
kann es ja eigentlich nicht mehr sagen
dass wir zu schwach also meistens
eingestuft als seine organisation sowohl
in deutschland als auch in der eu von
daher ist sie keinen der
gesprächspartnerin die gesprächspartner
sind die offiziellen autonomiebehörden
das wird auch so bleiben
sie erhalten unterstützung durch die
europäische union ja das ist richtig
in vier jahren etwa 1,3 milliarden euro
und wenn sie sehen der beitrag hat es ja
gezeigt dass wasserversorgung
stromversorgung und so weiter
gewährleistet werden muss
auch bildung und so weiter dahin geht
das geld es ist gewährleistet so
versichert ist uns die kommission dass
kein geld an die radikale hamas fließt
es gibt jetzt hier einen wunden punkt
ein bisschen und dafür sind sie auch
kritisiert worden als europäische union
die wahlen in den palästinensergebieten
sind ja vor kurzem relativ kurzfristig
verschoben worden offiziell wegen corona
inoffiziell kann man hören weil die
vertrag unter herrn abbas sorge hatte
dass sie sozusagen nicht siegreich
daraus hervorgeht die war der historisch
gewesen die erste seit 15 jahren
warum gibt es nicht die forderung an die
so verknüpft jetzt auch mit dieser
waffenruhe diese wahlen jetzt endlich
durchzuführen damit es eine legitimierte
regierung gibt nun die eu hat jetzt
wirklich die priorität dass die
kampfhandlungen aufhören also in diesem
in dieser gemengelage sind die wahlen
immer noch wichtig aber jetzt geht es
erstmal darum zu deeskalieren und das
wird alle kräfte brauchen wir wissen wie
verfahren die lage ist wir wissen dass
ich dass ich das ganze aufschaukelt das
sehen wir jetzt und das muss das absolut
vorrangiges ziel sein natürlich brauchen
wir diese wahlen das ist wichtig das ist
wichtig für eine legitimierung eines
ansprechpartners das haben sie richtig
beschrieben
aber wir müssen jetzt erst mal dafür
sorgen dass die genau auf ok aber sie
ist jetzt keine definierte kondition der
europäischen union
der israelische historiker moshe
zimmermann hat vor einigen tagen hier in
diesem programm den europäern einen
vorwurf gemacht der hat gesagt die
europäer haben seit 2014 das waren
sozusagen die letzten größeren
kampfhandlungen die dinge einfach laufen
lassen
was sagen sie dazu sie haben ja selber
gesagt ein langer konflikt ein sehr
langer konflikt und wenn man ehrlich auf
die auf das agieren der eu schaut dann
muss man auch kritisch sagen langer zeit
hat die eu sich da auch die usa
verlassen
das endete mit donald trump er seine art
der außenpolitik auch in diesem konflikt
gezeigt hat also eine sehr polternde art
die nicht dem entspricht wie die
europäische union außenpolitik betreibt
jetzt haben wir die beiden als neuen
partner an die stille diplomatie haben
sie angesprochen
wir müssen versuchen gemeinsam eine auf
eine lösung hinzuwirken auf eine
langfristige lösung vor allen dingen es
ist gut dass wir jetzt wieder in
verlässlichen partner auf der
amerikanischen seite haben aber die eu
musste ich auch immer mit ihren ich
denke das ist das was man von der eben
tatsächlich fordern muss was schwierig
wird mit 27 mitgliedstaaten mit sehr
unterschiedlichen okay vielleicht noch
eine kurze schluss einschätzung mit der
hoffnung dass die
das noch hält sie haben die amerikaner
angesprochen wie könnte das jetzt
arbeitsteilig mit einem neuen
us-präsidenten im weißen haus dann
laufen zwischen eu und usa gerade
bezogen auf diesen konflikt nun dass
darüber einen jetzt stille diplomatie
betreibt ist eine aktive abgrenzen gegen
die kräuter oder art von donald trump
und das ist meine hoffnung dass sehr
viel hinter den kulissen geschieht denn
solche komplizierten lange andauernden
konflikte lassen sich am ende nicht so
sehr auf offener bühne lösen das muss
mit viel diplomatischem geschick mit
vielen gesprächen geschrieben und da
müssen und das war die expertise und die
einschätzung von katarina barley spd
vize präsidentin des europäischen
parlaments er im phoenix tagesgespräch
wir danken herzlich nach brüssel einen
guten tag für sie